hi there steve kaufman and i'm going on
another 90 day challenge
uh in fact at link we're launching
another 90 day challenge there will be
announcements or there have been
announcements and so i'm gonna do it
again
by the way if you enjoy my channel
please subscribe
i am gonna do korean again and the
reason is that i still don't understand
korean very well
and i'm limited in what i can say
so
you know i've spent i've been on and off
with korean and finally i want to get to
a better level i'm not going to say
total fluency but a lot better level and
this gets me to what i think is
important in in a 90-day challenge in
the kinds of goals that we set for
ourselves i'm going to set myself a goal
in terms of my activity level what i'm
going to spend time on and how much time
i'm going to spend
i don't know what my ultimate
achievement will be and we never know
for sure
but if we stay on task
then we will improve
so
my known words total uh in korean that
link is around 33 000.
i want to get it over 50 maybe up to 60
thousand
60 000 so i'm gonna add
seven to ten thousand new words to my
passive vocabulary
i know from experience that once my
known words total the way we count them
at link where every form of the word is
a different word
once that gets over 40 50 000 my
comprehension really improves i've seen
that with polish with ukrainian and so
forth so i want to remove that korean
known words total up i'm also going to
try to speak once a week to hannah who
is from korea one of our link members
who participated in the the link academy
live program
uh i find now that we have uh for those
of you who are not yet on the beta on
your
uh iphone ipad
uh the way we do our our you know closed
test flash card dictation multiple
chores it's on a random basis i'm really
enjoying that because you can't just do
the same thing over and over so the fact
that these come at me randomly
i find that my korean my interest in
korean has increased i'm doing the
dictation i have to type in korean and
so my whole engagement with korean has
improved
i've got some good content that i found
some kbs dramas
that hannah was kind enough to
transcribe for me
uh some other material i found so
my challenge is going to be korean
i'm going to try to get over 50 close to
60 000 total new words at link
i want you if you're going to be in the
challenge set yourself an activity
you're going to maintain your activity
index beyond a certain level or you're
going to create so many links
i think i'll probably create 20 000
links because i normally create as many
links as my new words because the new
words come at me incidentally and then i
have these links and i tend to leave
them as links so i can see them in
yellow
and that helps me remember them and
notice phrases and stuff like that so
there you have it another 90-day
challenge i'm committing myself to spend
the time with korean and i expect that
the results will speak for themselves
thank you very much so sign up for your
90-day challenge
hi one thing more on this 90 day
challenge we want you to work with us to
promote it a little bit on social media
promote it with the
link challenge and if you do that uh
once a week we're gonna choose one
person who will receive a free link
t-shirt
also if you will ask a question of me
again using social media and with the
hashtag
link challenge
once a week we will choose a question
which we will answer and if you are
chosen you will get a 15 minute
conversation with me in any language you
want to discuss whatever you're
interested in
probably something to do with language
learning so let's see if we can generate
some enthusiasm and excitement around
the link challenge and remember on
social media add the hashtag
link challenge
happy challenge